Trascrizione: Paola Zorzan
Revisore: Barbara Dalla Villa
Ho fatto un piccolo test.
Ho chiesto alle persone
che incontro tutti i giorni
quale parola o idea associassero
nella loro mente alla parola limite.
[LIMITE]
Provate a farlo anche voi ora.
Provate a pensare a quale idea,
a quale parola vi viene in mente
pensando alla parola "limite".
Il risultato di questo test
mi ha fatto molto riflettere
In tanti hanno risposto definendo
la parola limite con un sinonimo
limite come confine,
confine geografico
quindi un limite fisico,
barriera,
oppure limite come qualcosa
di interno: blocco, argine.
In tanti, però, hanno associato
alla parola "limite" la parola "superare".
Ma cosa vuol dire davvero
superare il limite?
Io me lo chiedo molto spesso
nelle mie giornate.
E per spiegarvi come mai mi è così caro
questo tema, devo raccontarvi una storia.
Questa sono io.
Qui avevo quasi tre anni.
Ero una bimba vispa, tenace,
una bella rompiscatole insomma.
Già allora avevo una certa
propensione per le sfide
e per cercare di capire
qual era il limite.
Arrivare a toccarlo e, se possibile,
superarlo un po'.
Per farmi familiarizzare
con il concetto di limite e di sfida
i miei genitori avevano deciso,
più o meno all'asilo,
che avrei fatto il liceo classico.
Alla scuola media mi convinsero
a fare il fisico nucleare
perché mia madre aveva sentito dire
che era facile vincere il premio Nobel.
Ovviamente le cose non sono andate
esattamente così
anche se il liceo classico
l'ho fatto veramente.
Sono diventata un'ingegnere biomedico
e dopo non molto tempo
sono diventata mamma.
Prima di Martino, e poi di Matilde.
I figli, si sa, ti stravolgono la vita.
Diciamo che i miei
l'hanno proprio rivoluzionata.
Ve li presento meglio.
Lui è Martino,
adesso ha quasi tredici anni
è un ragazzino molto vispo,
piuttosto intelligente,
curioso, tenace.
Ha il naso della mamma e
gli occhi del papà.
Perché si spera che dai genitori
prendano solo le cose migliori.
E ha un sorriso e uno sguardo
capaci di rivoltare come un calzino
non solo la mamma, ma anche tutti quelli
con cui ha a che fare.
Lui è sempre Martino.
Com'è naturale che sia
la vostra attenzione, probabilmente,
ora è stata catturata dal suo limite.
Martino ha avuto
un'emorragia cerebrale perinatale.
Ha una tetraparesi spastica,
un danno motorio gravissimo.
Muove in maniera autonoma e controllata
solo gli occhi e un po' la testa.
E' davvero un ragazzino molto vispo
e intelligente, curioso, molto tenace.
Era tutto vero quello che ho detto.
Ed è anche
estremamente sensibile e molto ironico.
Perdonatemi per questo giochino.
Mi serviva per farvi capire meglio
Qual è la sfida che quotidianamente
si gioca per me davanti a lui.
E non vale solo per Martino:
vale per tutti noi.
In lui è solo più evidente.
Ogni giorno io devo decidere
se guardare solo il suo limite
il mio limite,
oppure andare oltre.
Ma cosa vuol dire superare il limite
quando è così evidente
che non si può negare,
non si può cancellare.
Cosa vuol dire vedere un'opportunità reale
per la propria vita, in questo caso?
Quand'ero piccola,
andava di moda una storia.
La storia di Pollyanna.
Io avevo questa edizione,
profumata al passion fruit,
che adesso trovo disgustosa,
ma allora adoravo.
Pollyanna era una bambina
molto sfortunata.
Aveva perso entrambi i genitori,
e viveva con una zia cattivissima.
Il padre, prima di morire,
le aveva insegnato un gioco.
Il gioco della felicità.
Questo gioco consisteva nel trovare
il lato positivo in tutte le cose.
Il gioco era nato così:
Pollyanna aveva chiesto in dono
una bambola
e aveva ricevuto delle stampelle.
Di fronte alla sua evidente delusione
il padre le aveva detto:
Ma no, Pollyanna, non essere triste!
Queste stampelle ti renderanno
infinitamente più felice
della bambola che desideravi.
Perché ogni volta che le guarderai
penserai a come sei fortunata tu
a non doverle usare.
Ecco, io ho sempre pensato che questa
fosse una tremenda idiozia.
Peraltro Pollyanna alla fine della storia
perde l'uso di entrambe le gambe
ma lasciamo perdere,
questa è un'altra storia.
Scusami Pollyanna.
Se cambiare prospettiva,
se guardare la realtà in un altro modo
non è il gioco della felicità
di Pollyanna, che cos'è, allora?
A me è capitata una cosa nella vita
che mi è stata di grande aiuto
in questa sfida quotidiana
di guardare la realtà in un'altra maniera.
Vorrei presentarvela, si chiama Matilde.
Per tutti noi è Titti.
Nove anni, quasi nove anni
di pura energia.
(Applausi)
E le ho chiesto di aiutarmi.
Di raccontarvi con le sue stesse parole,
se se la sente,
che cosa vuol dire per lei
vivere a casa nostra con Martino.
(Applausi)
Con Martino puoi parcheggiare
vicino ai posti.
Poi, però, se ci sono le scale,
dobbiamo tornare in macchina,
perché lui ha le ruote.
Marty non deve mai fare
le salite a piedi
e nemmeno camminare quando è stanco.
Anzi, non deve mai camminare.
Lui può stare sempre seduto.
Marty può portare le cose pesanti
senza far fatica
tanto le attacchi alla carrozza,
e poi lo spinge qualcun altro.
Marty non deve mai
mettere a posto i giochi
Perché, in verità,
non li può neanche mettere in disordine.
Marty non deve mai fare
le interrogazioni orali
perché non parla.
Cioè, sa parlare il "martolese",
che è tipo "aensi, oain"
ma non lo capisce quasi nessuno,
a parte me.
Marty può stare sotto al palco
ai concerti e nelle partite di calcio
allo stadio, può stare in posti speciali
dove si vede benissimo
oppure a bordo campo.
Se fai un mercatino,
o vendi le limonate nella strada,
e ti porti Marty con te
ti danno più soldi.
(Risate)
perché è disabile.
Poi però gli do la sua percentuale,
non è che i soldi me li tengo tutti.
Marty non va mai a scuola
con il pullman.
Questo può essere un vantaggio,
oppure no.
Dipende se la bidella è cattiva.
Essere Marty può sembrare difficile,
ma dietro ai problemi
ci possono essere dei super vantaggi.
Per scoprilo bisogna provare.
Grazie Titti.
(Applausi)
Per scoprirlo bisogna provare.
Come avete potuto intuire,
ho delle belle sfide educative, io,
quotidianamente.
Quindi, se superare il limite
non è stravolgere la realtà.
Ma è guardarla tutta,
fino in fondo,
con il realismo
che ci ha insegnato Matilde
cosa nasce da questo sguardo?
Vorrei portarvi solo un paio di esempi
di che cosa è successo a me,
concretamente, quando sono riuscita
a guardare il limite così.
Il primo è un progetto personale.
E' un piccolo brand di accessori
e abbigliamento per bambini, appunto.
Che è nato proprio
da una delle manifestazioni
più evidenti del limite di Martino.
Perché quando aveva circa quattro anni
perdeva tantissima saliva
e lui è sempre stato un bimbo
molto attento a essere bello e stiloso.
E non voleva mettere i bavaglini
da bambino piccolo.
Io, che ho sempre amato il cucito,
ho iniziato a pensare
come potevo risolvere questo problema?
Di lì, ho creato
dei bavaglini che non sembrassero tali
che fossero degli accessori belli
e performanti.
Da questi bavaglini è nata un'intera linea
di accessori per bambini
e un progetto che, appunto,
mi ha regalato e mi regala
tante soddisfazioni.
Il secondo esempio che vorrei farvi
riguarda, invece,
il mio lavoro di ignegnere,
di ingegnere biomedico.
Come potete immaginare, l'arrivo dei figli
ha condizionato, fortemente,
anche la mia carriera lavorativa.
Purtroppo, nel 2019 è ancora vero che
avere dei figli,
e avere dei figli disabili,
costituisce un limite
dal punto di vista professionale.
Tuttavia, è successo che,
a un certo punto,
mi sono resa conto di come il conoscere
il bisogno, essere care-giver,
e conoscere il bisogno dall'interno
era un valore aggiunto
anche per il mio lavoro.
Univo le competenze tecniche
alla conoscenza del bisogno da dentro.
Di qui sono nati tanti progetti
di co-progettazione di ausili
sia per Martino, che poi
per altri ragazzini.
Vi cito solo l'ultimo che è un progetto
coordinato da Polifactory
del Politecnico di Milano.
In collaborazione con l'associazione
Fight the Stroke
all'interno di un grande progetto Europeo.
Lo scopo è quello di
progettare un ausilio
per l'accesso facilitato al suono
e alla musica
per ragazzini affetti da paralisi
cerebrale infantile, appunto,
e siamo già in fase
di prototipazione dell'ausilio.
Vi invito a fare un ultimo
e ulteriore passaggio.
Accettare il limite, abbracciarlo,
attraversarlo
significa quindi rassegnazione?
Significa abbassare il tiro nella vita?
O desiderare il massimo?
Per noi significa
desiderare il massimo.
Chiedere tutto:
con realismo, ma tutto.
Una vita piena, a bordo campo,
dove ci si gode lo spettacolo migliore.
Martino ama la velocità
e ci siamo inventati
degli sport estremi
per potergliela far provare.
Ama l'avventura ed esplorare
il mondo e la natura.
Adora il mare e l'acqua.
Ama molto divertirsi e andare alle feste.
E ...
ama molto stare al centro dell'attenzione.
Ha una certa passione per la musica
e spesso andiamo insieme ai concerti.
Colleziona le bacchette
che i batteristi gli regalano
alla fine del concerto.
E' un grande tifoso del Milan,
e appena può va con il papà allo stadio.
Ma la sua vera grande passione è il cibo.
Ama andare nei ristoranti belli
e vuole diventare uno chef.
Non sappiamo se riuscirà a farlo
nel senso convenzionale del termine
ma noi stiamo facendo di tutto perché
lui possa realizzare il suo desiderio.
I suoi desideri sono grandi.
E la vera sfida per noi
è riuscire a guardare ad essi
attraversando il limite.
Quindi, sta a te decidere.
Sta a te decidere
se guardare tutta la realtà
con realismo, non fermandoti al limite
ma attraversandolo e arrivando
fino alla profondità dei tuoi desideri
e vivere ogni giorno
all'altezza di essi.
Che forse sono una delle poche cose
che abbiamo davvero senza limiti.
Tutti. Nessuno escluso.
Io vi ringrazio
per avere guardato con me
le diapositive delle vacanze
di tutta la famiglia.
In questo talk
so che ho posto tante domande.
Forse c'è qualche buona intuizione.
Qualche imprevisto.
Ma poche risposte.
Insomma, è un po' come la vita.
Grazie.
(Applausi)